in the far north of iraq sidhu province
an ancient mesopotamian town now called
ahmadiyya
lies 1400 meters above sea level
the climate and soil conditions in the
area are good for growing crops
especially sesame
almadia has been famous for its tahini
for centuries
with a staple food paste produced by
traditional methods
suleiman hussein's factory has been in
the family for generations
he says it operates seven months a year
between october and june
that's the rainy season when there's
enough water
and the currents are strong enough to
turn the water mills
the factory water mill was constructed
350 years ago and it's still producing
the same tasty tahini because we use
locally grown sesame soaked in well
water and roasted by firewood
after they're dried the seeds are put in
a stone oven heated by firewood
then follows a labor-intensive stirring
process
for a couple of hours to ensure they're
completely roasted
a water mill driven grinder then turns
them into a smooth paste
the grinder's millstone is turned by
hydropower from underneath the water
cools off the millstone's temperature so
that any seeds won't be burned
workers in this factory say they produce
between 70 and 80 tons of tahini a year
tahini is a favorite food
throughout the arab region
but for our maria families traditional
tahini is not only part of their diet
to face the cold weather in the
mountains
it has also become part of their
heritage
eighty-year-old hasan al-ahmadi says
they've always depended on what they can
grow in the area for their nutritional
needs as food security is a daily
struggle
our founding fathers created this dish
to help them move around heights and
valleys to work in farms as a child i
remember we used it as a dietary
supplement
the people of ahmadiyya say proudly that
customers from across iraq visit the
town just to buy its tahini it's
believed the first tahini water mill was
built by kurdish rulers in the 16th
century
what's not known is how long traditional
mills will keep running without the
introduction of some modern technology
al-jazeera in ahmadiyya town northern
iraq